[Music]
we all have objects that may look
ordinary to others but which have
special meaning in our lives for
photographers Shana Novak that included
a set of spoons given to her by her
grandmother a few years ago she took
this picture and turned simple
silverware into a compelling work of art
and now that's a service she provides to
the world finding the extraordinary in
the ordinary for a growing list of
grateful clients vladimir duthiers is
here with her story good morning good
morning those precious keepsakes that
may be stored in the back of a closet
they are just the items Shana Novak
wants you to see in a whole new light I
had the chance to meet up with her in a
New York studio and see how one families
typically ordinary item was hiding its
own rich history what did you guys think
when you saw it when you saw it first
time a simple pair of red sneakers
something you could find in almost any
Closet in America I'll show you where
they live but to the Barlowe family in
Chicago
these shoes are a family heirloom here
they are how did these sneakers come
into your possession so Dan I went to
London when we were first dating in our
young 20s and we wanted to buy something
when we were there I saw these red
Saucony sneakers but he was like let's
buy those and they'll be our you know
London purchase he kept them in the
bottom of his closet for all of the
years and was like wait you still have
these sneakers oh my gosh the Barlow's
are just one of hundreds of clients who
turned to still life photographer Shana
Novak to capture a piece of their
family's history in a single shot how do
we know those of us who have old things
if they're heirlooms or not that's an
awesome question it is an heirloom if
you say it is rightfully named the air
Loomis Shana credits the inspiration for
starting conversations behind these
everyday objects to her grandmother
Phyllis she had in her apartment
organized closet with boxes completely
organized packed with all of the things
that our family holds special and the
idea that it could be anything as long
as it held a story when you are
photographing them do you keep that in
mind
yeah it's humbling it definitely makes
me respect the object or have fun with
the object nobody I love to get a little
backstory before I start so that I know
what I'm dealing with but yes absolutely
understanding the sentiment behind each
item Shana receives is part of her
creative process a woman from Maryland
was having a pair of jeans photographed
for her husband I got a pair of jeans
yes and come to find out the jeans saved
him from being burned in a fire in
college while most artifacts sent in to
be heirloom are on the personal side
Shana has had the opportunity to work
with a few pieces that have a wider
historical impact a woman from Kansas
sent us her father's Air Force helmet
that he had worn in Vietnam and he was
captain he flew one of the planes that
accompany JFK's body back to Washington
it was so fragile and it had been
through so much that I pretty much had
to sit down and just take a moment and
think about where this helmet had been
she's photographed other relics for more
recent military engagements like the
combat boots of ABC News's Bob Woodruff
who suffered a traumatic brain injury
when an AED exploded near his convoy in
2006 I was actually working with his
wife who celebrates an alive day every
year to celebrate Bob's recovery from
his injuries that he sustained reporting
in Iraq years ago after ten years it was
time to bring the boots out we got him
on set and they still had dust from Iraq
and there was some blood on them and the
laces had been cut off and that sort of
set the tone for I think the reverence
of it all behind the scenes the prepping
positioning and lighting takes hours of
work so this is you're right now working
on this microscope yes so take me
through it
we'll set our object down on some clean
white paper and we'll start playing
around with the lights and the color
we're sort of into what does this
microscope want where do the highlights
really show off its attributes are you
thinking
the person who views this will also be
able to tell that there's a story behind
this particular object yeah we always
try to make the object look sort of
heroic because we like to have fun we
want to be positive we want them to have
good feelings for the Barlow family a
recent redesign of their house redefined
how they see their heirloom anchoring
their story to the wall of their home we
stopped we came in and saw it and he was
like wait a minute
those are your tennis shoes you know we
got a little teary eyed and he got a
little teary eyed because it's an
heirloom right it's not a fancy piece of
china or engraved piece of silver but it
was something that meant a lot to me and
Annie and it was a great surprise so we
should point out that the Barlow's Dan
and Annie they actually grew apart they
broke up and he kept the sneakers the
entire time that they were together
maybe that's why they came back well
exactly right and so when they took
these this beautiful photograph and they
had this heirloom piece of art that's
the thing that yeah I heard you reacting
Anthony to the fact that when I first
met Shaina well I thought heirloom meant
yeah a piece of jewelry from your
great-grandparents writing and it really
doesn't it could be anything that has
meaning to you anything that feels as
she says heroic and I mean there's some
of these items they do feel kind of
heroic it's really it's really neat yeah
really cool thanks flad